Okay, so for this exercise, I've loaded up from the supplied project
one of the levels, the hero end level, and I've deleted all the lights
to make sure that we can actually light this up.
So let's go ahead and go through the process of what
creating a scene like this and lighting it statically would look like.
So first of all I'll just create some lights to actually
get the look that I want. So you'll notice we've already got a Directional
Light that's doing some work but let's go ahead and add some more.
So we'll add, let's add a Rectangular Light in here and I'm going to go ahead
and place it in such a way to get some nice
light information here. I'm going to increase the attenuation and increase the
intensity a little bit, there we go. Just going to move it back a bit and
in this case I'm going to also change the source width a little
bit so that we get a little bit more light at the back here.
Now you'll notice I'm having this one as stationary so that we get that nice
direct shadow but I could have it just a static
and bake everything so that's something to keep in mind.
Let's go ahead and give this a little bit of color as well, let's go
with a slight orange, nice and subtle. So you'll notice that already because
this asset here is, or this scene here
is using static lights or stationary lights,
Unreal is already telling us, hey you need to build lighting, right?
So all we're seeing here is essentially currently a preview.
Let's go ahead and hit it with a bit of light on the back side here
and in this case I'll just keep the values the same but make the light
maybe blue to get a nice look. I'll do the same over the back here,
just have a simple three light system here.
I might not even cast shadows on this one just to avoid
too much shadow changes, so if we just search shadow here
here's a nice option here where you don't have to cast
shadows at all. Okay so we have our basic setup, now importantly we're
going to need a Lightmass Importance Volume, this is a Post Process Volume
that's here already so let's go ahead and add our Lightmass
Importance Volume and remember this will essentially
determine where we will get high quality
lightmass calculations in terms of indirect lighting.
So let's go ahead and make sure that our entire section here is encompassed,
so within this we'll get high quality lighting.
And now we wanted to change the settings themselves we'd have to find
the world settings, so we're going to go to Window
and find World Settings, here we go, and when we go to Lightmass we've got
the options here that we were looking at before in the
slideshow that had the number of
indirect lighting bounces and that kind of information. So change the values over
here if you want to, let's say for example we choose to
have eight bounces instead of three so we
get a bit higher quality indirect lighting and now we're ready to
build. So what I'm going to do is go to Build and now before I do
anything I'm going to build in preview mode so that I can sort of
see if this is going to look good and then after that if I wanted to I
could go higher up but it's best to first build in preview mode so that
you can actually see if there's any issues or errors without
having to spend ages waiting for the engine to bake the lighting. So
we're going to go ahead and I'm going to press build all levels, you could
also build lighting only but in this case I want to build everything so I'm
going to press build all levels and you'll see it will start to set
up a connection with Swarm which is the offline renderer that will build our
Lightmass. Now you'll notice we're going ahead
with it it's now building lighting. If you want to see what's actually
happening you can load up the swarm agent so if you just go to your tray
here and double click swarm you'll see we have what's actually
going on in the light builder. So you see it's color coded
currently it's doing its skylight radiosity and as it
compiles all of this you can see we started caching over radiance so
collecting some photons and all the information that you see
here. Now I'm going to pause the video because this is going to build and
might take a few minutes but we'll come back to see the results.
Okay so a few minutes have gone by and Unreal Engine's now finished
building lighting so I'm going to go ahead and close the swarm agent
and take a look at what this looks like. So it takes a little bit for
Unreal to wake up and see it and you can see we've got kind of
artifact shadows and that's essentially the
limitation or drawback of using static lighting and especially when you
just build in preview mode so if we were to build
this at a higher lighting quality we would get much nicer
shadows but again this is a really good way of
previewing for yourself if anything's going to be wrong and I can see that
this looks fine so I would now go ahead and go okay well
I'm going to go and change my building quality to production
and then build all levels. Let's go ahead
and allow you to do this on your own since it takes quite a while to build
in production mode but looking forward to seeing your
results.